in recent years technical innovations
have been transforming life on the
continent of Africa for example
cellphone networks have sprung up in
places that never had landlines fueling
revolutionary advances in communications
Commerce and finance one tech firm is
now creating another kind of opportunity
in Africa for young people in need of
good jobs
Kylie Atwood has a story from Lagos
Nigeria sleek desk casual dress code
free lunch it's what you'd expect to see
in Silicon Valley but this is Nigeria
where money from US investors is being
used to train a new generation of
software engineers as you can see the
informal economy is alive and well here
in Lagos but Africa is attracting more
and more tech startups in 2017 alone
Africa attracted more than half a
billion dollars in start-up funding Hana
Mozilla is a software engineer at and
Ella
one of Africa's top tech startups she
grew up in a rural village in Kenya
where options seem limited my mind was
just revolving around farming and well
kids are married off as earliest off
young girls are married I was just like
well life will take me I'll just cause
it's shocking make young a movie like oh
wow how did you even do this you know I
feel for the kids back in the village
make you can do this it's forced to
leave her village when ethnic clashes
broke out Hannah went to high school
nearby and decided to become an engineer
until finding and Ella online she was
set to become the problem solver at home
yeah family does TV Juanita crushes just
tell folks and any boat I did totally
think that big sandy Suleiman the
company's president of global operations
recruits talent across Africa Jess's he
returned to Lagos after 11 years in the
United States you went to college in the
US you worked for some big US tech
companies consulting firms you went to
Harvard Business School right
you had offers at places like Facebook
and Google afterwards do a tango why are
you here this is the future I think
ultimately we are creating an economy
in the technology industry which is
going to spark a massive revolution on
the continents and I'm seeing it happen
every day
so the impact we we have an impact I can
have as an individual it's just so
tangible and so meaningful being here
that's home so like who doesn't want to
change home in 2016 the company got a 24
million dollar infusion led by
Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg who followed
up with a visit and the whole room just
erupts people cannot believe it and he
actually stood in front of the group and
addressed them and he told them he said
you guys are the future of technology
what does it mean to have the Mark
Zuckerberg seal of approval when you
have someone who is probably considered
the most important person in tech
physically spanning you office telling
you about how he believes in you it has
a way of just validating everything
you're doing the coding done by and
ellas developers helps American tech
companies innovate from New York to
Pittsburgh to San Francisco with almost
a thousand coders so far in dello is
looking to expand our ideas we started
in 2014 and we said in 10 years we would
have helped to empower a hundred
thousand developers in Africa which
takes us to 2024 a hundred thousand
developers yes that's a plan and in that
same amount of time there's going to be
a shortage of almost a million
developers in the US domestically right
so American companies are going to be
looking and you guys know that
absolutely we're we're also a business
competition is fierce so what is the
acceptance rate of applicants to people
who actually get to work here some 1.7%
0.74 yes less than 1% less than 1%
what's Harvard's acceptance rate more
than 1% changing conceptions about what
a coder looks like and where they come
from is igniting enthusiasm and Hannah
Mozilla wants her story to inspire
younger African generations it doesn't
have to be programming but just
yes yes for CBS this morning Saturday
Kylie Atwood Lagos Nigeria very proud of
Kylie for that report Nigeria is I lived
in Nigeria for almost three years it's a
wonderful place to work and report from
but it can be challenging yeah and I
just said to you I wonder if they're
more men coding or women there yeah it's
good question interesting yeah